you know what it is but is this rhetoric
that actually then is pumped into these
mines and creates what people not
complaining about the misogynistic world
that's what it is Independent Schools is
prefer women that are more it's not that
it's but it's not that's not the problem
the problem is now listen the maths is
very simple you've got people like Angie
Tate talking about these things with
such Clarity and it makes so much sense
because it is true right and then you
have men that are in these situations
where just average working an average
job and they cannot fulfill whatever
definition is called to be a man in
these yes they can and that's no they
said he didn't say that yes they can no
a nine to five man can do it